peu
[Musique]
la course de sardines à l'huile votre
récepteur est inclinée à 45 degrés vous
prenez une boîte de sardines à l'huile à
la tomate ça ne marche pas vous versez
le contenu de cette boîte sur l'écran de
votre récepteur
si toutefois c'était insuffisant vous
prenez une bouteille une bouteille
d'huile ordinaire vous versez n'ayez pas
peur vous pouvez en mettre le plus
possible client ya mieux ça va vous
prenez une sardine que vous placer en
haut de l'écran de votre récepteur 1-2-3
partait pour les malchanceux une
deuxième manche
un deux trois parts et que ceux qui ont
gagné nous écrire
non messieurs vous n'auriez pas une
allumette s'il vous plaît une allumette
oui certainement monsieur tarder je
crois je crois que j'en ai une dans la
poche du bas non dans les poches du lot
non plus qu est ce qui se passe sous
contention garder tout arrêter suivant
un sur deux le warwick c'est parce que
attendait ah ben voilà
abbas est un cure dent ça va très bien
non ne bougez pas je vais vous la
retrouvez sais pas ce que je vais vous
dire ça ça n'est pas la baisse de tous
les jours je tiens vous permettez je
tiens à vous la donne et c'est parce que
c'est idiot mais c'est ses poches année
elles sont toujours trop petit on en met
toujours partout on s'énerve quand on
cherche les abats voilà abba stature ça
va très bien s'adapter ou le commandant
regarder ça je vais vous dire c'est
idiot mais c'est parce que c'est ccist
ailleurs au collège avait dit faire une
poche là il a fait la joie des pains
farines ici ils avaient là vous savez ce
que c'est évidemment leader au général
on est donc cette part je dis je vais
retrouver à savoir si ces étudiants mais
ça ça c'est encore ma femme on connaît
le secteur méchant votants de dire
qu'elle va pas ça très bien non mais moi
j'aime pas je me dis je vais retrouver
ça ça m'énerve qu'on met des choses à
leur place ne le reprenne un brouillard
tout mais ce qu'elle avait même des
limites quand la fin du show biz comme
une sanction dont je suis sûre de
terrain avant monsieur vous j'ai appris
quand même simplement une allumette a
été courte dans ce jeu là mais je n'ai
que ça va très bien sa valeur était là
quand j'ai déjà ma femme me dit on va
vous la chaussée le temps d'avoir peur
mais certains veulent se souvient trick
qu'est ce que c'est une allumette
fallait c'était pas la peine de
s'énerver comme vous d'yverdon seulement
maintenant plec merci jean prière merci
seulement maintenant chez merci bien je
suis sûr je suis sûr que vous n'avez pas
de boîte double oui non et je pas bête
mais je n'ai pas peur car nous savons
bien que vous permettez je veux faire
plaisir
pardon tu fais un plaisir de vous a
retenu une parce que ça une boîte j'en
ai vu d'anormal rien merci beaucoup
d'être fâché fâché je me couchais pas
rester ça je vais la retrouver c'est
parce que je veux dire c'est pas ma vie
je n'ai pas très bien vous l'avez déjà
lui aussi beaucoup je me dis que j'ai
passés par je voudrais pas formé de
complète partout moi ça m'énerve ou
comblé parce que c'est cet ailleurs je
voudrais faire une position sinon je me
réjouis je n'ai pas peur des mots à leur
fameuse et me laisser partir
ça y est c'est encore ma force
pas fou non ça ne va pas non je veux
simplement une à lunettes parce que j'ai
quelque chose en attend là et je vais
envie de quelque chose que j'ai dans la
temps voilà c'est tout faux pas votre
faut pas vous vous énervez comme ça
m'énerve pas du tout les normes en fin
bouillon il faut faut savoir garder son
calme dans la vie enfin quand même dans
la rue comme ça un grand gaillard comme
vous calmez vous calmez vous calmez vous
tient mais vous calmez vous allô allô
allô allô qu'est ce que c'est que ce
qu'est ce qu'un halo halo
il faut il faut le dire tout de suite ce
que vous voulez c'est un cure-dent ne
faut pas pleurer comme ça des kurdes en
cinq journées attendait cheville jamais
ordonné une chez vous des battures d'un
bon désormais cheveux lâchés leur toit
et c'est parce que sinon mais si tu sais
pas ce que c'est pas mal de messages ans
déjà j'ai foutu n'est pas la cei a pu
sortir ce soir c'est la même chose c'est
dur c'est aux hommes à femmes
non mais ça ça m'énerve parce que
j'avais 18 ans maison toujours 100 ou
non mais ça ça me
je suis sur eux mêmes mesdames et
messieurs voici notre jeu bête et
méchant pour faire ce jeu il nous faut
une une émission avec des poissons vous
n'attendrez pas longtemps il a souvent à
la télévision
vous prenez une pince monseigneur vous
des clous et le dessus de votre
récepteur vous tâtez si l'eau est bonne
ça va elle est bonne on peut y aller
elle est très bonne
c'est bon ça pique ça gratte ça
chatouille hop vous ferrez j'ai attrapé
deux poissons que ceux qui ont attrapé
plus que moi nous écrivent ils ont gagné
et maintenant le pire des français le
français femmes elles ont cherché c'est
à dire madame ruth à chaud ce serait
rapport à vos anomalies question de
déclarations de février au qu'il parle
bien
où mes hommes le mawlid il redit le
encore donc j'aime tourner j'aime ton
père et ta bouche pulpeuse team chercher
des voyous et depuis la mort de monsieur
route à chaud vous n'avez rien rien rien
déclaré alors je m qu'il ya des gars je
déclare la sto grosse bête avide
d'argent et de plaisir mais s'appelle
comme nous tous a dit moi un une
déclaration d'impôt sur le revenu des
personnes physiques non je vous demande
comment tu t'appelles monstre de guinée
mais c'est joli ce petit nom c'est pas
mon petit non madame ruth à chaud on
petit nom c'est rené remet aux revenus
que toi tais toi tu as menée chez me
fall mais pourquoi mathieu attiré
d'intérêt 10 10 espèces de petites
brutes dit et moi qui me le sol
mesdames et messieurs voici notre jeu
bête et méchant pour faire ce jeu il
vous faut en voisin le voisin s'occupe
de la deuxième chaîne vous vous occupez
de la première vous placez votre poste
récepteur sur des roues de voiture
d'enfant ça roule fait sauter le
couvercle et vous montez
dassier vient de dents au préalable vous
avez tracée une bande qu'il va vous
falloir franchir en avant
inviter tous vos voisins à faire ce jeu
d'après vos réponses nous pourront
déduire qu'elle est la meilleure des
deux chaînes
[Musique]